is it possible for someone who has a
normal income to do this diet meat is
expensive is it not it's totally
possible to do this on a very low budget
it can be way cheaper than eating the
standard American diet what you want to
do is you want to go to a butcher or go
to your meat department and just buy the
cheap Cuts doesn't matter what they are
buy the cheap Cuts you could survive off
of tongue if you needed to that's dirt
cheap and if you go to my handy website
liondiet.com there is a recipe for
crunchy things and you can literally
make the most garbage cuts into
delicious crispy things by adding fat so
you can buy fat from a butcher fat is
really cheap they commonly cut fat off
of cuts and throw it away so make
friends with a butcher get the cheap
Cuts add fat get a pressure cooker and
an air fryer and you're set hey and the
pressure cooker and air fryer are an
upfront expense at the beginning of the
diet they will save you so much time and
they'll make your food so good it's
really worth investing into them